the stars of snow piercers daveed Diggs
was on last week Jennifer Connelly and
this man my buddy from back in the day
oh gotta meet him years ago on the ESPYs
I believe and on ESPN when he was the
Rick now he is a writer producer
showrunner and actor extraordinaire mike
omalley back here on the show how are
you Michael Rich Eisen great talking to
you today man so happy to be with you
I'm doing all right I'm surviving you
know I'm home with three teenagers on
lockdown mode still so we got a 17 year
old
we got a 15 year old 13 year old so it's
uh it's insane i I missed the youth
sport I would I'd do anything to sit in
the stands like this next to some dad I
want to punch in the throat I'll talk
about but I never thought I'd miss that
I miss it you never thought you'd miss
the parents who make life miserable for
youth sports but that is the way that
the world is turning right now Mike well
how did you get him how did you first
get involved and again you're you're big
on youth sports here and baseball for
sure about teaching kids the game and
the love of the game and all that what
did you how'd you get involved in that
yours I'm a schmuck I'm a schmuck rich
I'm a schmuck who you know believe that
the dad had to be around their sons I
hang out and have a good relationship
with them and I'd like any schmuck dad I
got suckered into it by some guy who
made it seem like it was a great thing
and then next thing I know I was doing
it and like I said any any time you can
leave a youth gym or a youth sports
field and not have gotten into a
fistfight with somebody I think is it is
a great day that's the victory for me
it's not about teaching kids the love of
the game realizing how much we're really
on you know humanity's on the on the
brink of you know war at any time
because of that rage that's within us to
have to sit next to people who don't
know what they're talking about like
what one year I mentioned it here on the
show I don't know if you were that was
why we had you call in once but I think
it was with with uh it wasn't this
particular but the Youth League that you
know that you are associated with here
son plays in and he you know he had a
manager who would set the lineup based
on that when the kid arrived so if you
brought your kid late if you brought
your kid late he would hit like 10th in
the order and then have to wait maybe
like three innings to hit so for the
final game I'm like which by the way
wasn't very fair to parents with like
two other kids in a Sunday oh it's just
my wife and I we were determined we were
gonna get our son to the game on time
for the last game for the last game of
the year and sure enough we got him in
the top of the order and he gets up
there and another fellow eight-year-old
hits him in the chops and the hot and he
goes right down and so I go out on the
field to make sure he's okay because he
never says a word whenever he gets hurt
and this time he was beginning to cry
and the umpire told him to take his base
Mike the umpire told him to take his
base and I started telling the umpire no
no we've been waiting a week for my son
to hit no no we got my son here on time
you have no idea what the hell was
happening in my house today and I was
suddenly with everybody watching
I was that dad going to an umpire who's
giving his time for this event I was
that guy I was that guy for a split
moment Mike you're allowed to be that
guy rich when your kid sports that I
figured out is that when your kid
strikes out or they make an error or you
know the opposite they get a hit it's
all primal oh my god my name is never
gonna go on this person is never gonna
meet a girl fall in love have children
because he can't succeed this is primal
this is it's just you know we've we've
taken it to two things like sports but
he was rich I'm sorry that happened okay
as the former president of that league
just I hope that that league mostly
brought you to are very much sort of
pain and we miss it right now we miss it
I mean so many so many young men and
women
in youth sports and obviously also high
schools spring sports being canceled
right now it has been very very
difficult that people waiting for their
senior years for their spring sports
before they graduate it's it's been
brutal you know and we don't you know I
think one of the things the kids don't
realize you realize it is as grown-ups
it's like you never whatever you're
driving your kid to a practice and you
know that kind of like god I'm tired I
want to go I got so much homework and
then if you were to cut to the drive
home when they're in a great mood it's
because you know that that energy that
they have from you know exercising and
being with their friends and joking
around and laughing it's just like when
you know when you go to do a workout you
never want to go do it you always feel
better after you did it and I think that
they're not able to make that connection
necessarily that's the difficult thing
is I mean if all of us come out of this
and every single kid abook you know is
depressed just from being watt in it
inside not being able to you know
exercise and and be with their friends I
mean that's a win you know
yep mike omalley here on the Rich Eisen
show are you gonna root for Brady in
Tampa Mike where are you on this I am
yes of course I want to root for a
mid-tempo music look he's that Tom Brady
has brought all New England fans and in
most football fans tremendous joy in
terms of how he he performed I mean I
know a lot of people don't like him
because he want a lot of Super Bowls and
beat their teams but I mean as a guy who
know rooted for the Patriots all growing
up and then got to be you know right
around 2000 they started to really take
off this guy is know brought so much joy
to our family and so yeah I brewed for
him I listen now I root from it as an
old guy you know as a 53 year old plan
yeah it's it's funny most Patriots fans
that I know and that includes the my
friend Chris Brockman is across the way
here who you met when no when you've
been around is that is that Brady going
to Tampa was just like okay you were
kind of kind of expecting tom to not not
return even those who might have held
out for thinking he would never leave
but Gronk going to that's the issue that
that's that's the one thing like that
comes back and he's gonna join Tom there
and that the reunions happens they're
not in New England that's what that's
kind of a tough swallow to take right
there it is but I think that you know I
think that Rob Gronkowski I really think
that he was not thinking about going
back and and playing I really do think
that he was retiring I I would love to
know you know I'd love to talk to him
and find out what the inside story was I
mean love it one of the reasons he's
going back to Tampa and of course
correct me if I'm wrong is that they
don't think that he's going to have to
do as much blocking as he was going to
have to do in the the Patriots offense
is that a is that a real reason you
think which I don't think so I just
think that he wasn't feeling physically
up to it or wasn't physically mentally
up for being going through the the you
know the the rigors of a season where
everybody's aiming for his knees and
below or his waist to his knees and go
through another Belichick crucible I
don't think he was up for that now that
he's feeling a little bit better he
misses the game he saw it and TB 12
calls him up and says how about you come
with me down to Florida
like everybody retires you spent some
time in Florida how about you with me
and with Ariane's and and and off we go
I think the answer was a thousand
percent yes that's what I have yeah yes
I we were interested I'm writing you
know I'm so in addition to acting and I
am doing this new show snowpiercer
it's on Sunday nights on TNT at 9
o'clock but I'm also writing and running
a show I had written on shameless for a
bunch of years and then got more into
the writing and now I'm running a show
that's gonna be done in Atlanta that
James Harrison we just cast to former
NFL players in this show okay miles
Burris and James Harrison and they're
both playing wrestlers in the show it's
about the independent wrestling
promotion in Atlanta not in Atlanta in
Georgia yes and the dough starring
Stephen ml and Alexander Ludwig and
we're just stoked well here's the thing
what James Harrison is when when you pay
him you need to pay him in cash in an
envelope will you do that for everybody
on occasion
James's Instagram you know that he works
out quite a bit I'm not going across
James Harris no understood understood so
again the manner on occasion apparently
there's an envelope and to him we're
assuming there's cash flow he's got to
report it to the IRS that's all I care
about I just want I want the roads to be
paved and I want the military to be able
to be funded that's all there you go
Mike O'Malley and before we do turn to
snowpiercer a little bit here let's
let's linger a little bit more on your
writing creating show running abilities
and what you did with LeBron James and
maverick Carter four stars
survivors remorse did you actually sit
down and work with LeBron or vice versa
at any point in time during this process
yeah well I mean you say what what what
I did for them it's more what they did
for me was what you know so you know
maverick Carter who I met through Tom
Warner Thomas of course that one of the
Red Sox indeed and owner a Liverpool
soccer look made you know made his name
producing television shows and I had
written some stuff with him that didn't
go and he introduced him to LeBron and
maverick and said would you be
interested in in writing and developing
this idea this premise that they have on
what it's like to grow up in a place
where you're you struggle you come from
nothing and then you you have success
and yet all the people that you love and
you cared about and you grew up and and
are still stuck in that place so that's
where the the notion of survivors were
Morris came from which is you know
maverick Carter is LeBrons business
partner he's the one who introduced me
to that phrase I had heard of you know
survivor's guilt and something that
happens when you know a ship is a
shipwreck or a plane crash
you lived someone else dies you don't
know why but attaching this idea and
this concept to growing up in the
projects in getting out and then feeling
this obligation to continuously throw
life preservers to other people who are
still there what's different about that
scenario is that those
folks they're still there they haven't
perished you can help them with a car
payment with health insurance payment
with alone and it never stops and
especially if the big hearted like
LeBron and maverick are and so they came
to me I wrote this show I went down I
flew down to Miami and I actually did a
table read of the show with LeBron and
maverick and in Randy purple there I
think his wife Savannah read a role it
was it was a real trip to be down there
reading the script with those guys but
you know that what what I loved about
working with LeBron and maverick is that
they said if it's happening in the world
it could happen on this show and so on
you know survivors Morrison's we did
four season go to show on Starz and
LeBron was in an episode maverick was
you know really involved as an executive
producer
you know LeBron said a couple times it
was great but they were very very
supportive of everyone and you know to
have that kind of support that wind at
your back was a great thing for me as a
as an emerging writer that's hey look
man and obviously maverick Carter and
LeBron James or are huge obviously in
their own right in their own worlds and
then to to enter with you and yours and
it's interesting you got you got to
introduce them from by Tom Werner owner
of the Red Sox I know if I'm breaking
any news to you the reason why Mookie
Betts is a Dodger is I think Mookie
wanted all of Tom's Rosanne money as for
every penny of his Roseann money and all
of John Henry's investment dollars it's
odd he's now a Dodger I think that's
what he want no Mike I think that ship
sailed brother I think that ship has
sailed and Mookie's not coming back he's
now he's not walking through that door
Mookie Betts please you guys getting
played this season I do I think it you
know we've been talking
quite a bit on this show Mike I I just
think that baseball at some points gonna
look at each other and said what the
hell are we doing here I know you don't
trust me I know I don't trust you I know
we have a level of dismiss trust and
distrust that's that that's difficult to
bridge but we're gonna figure this thing
out because the last thing we're gonna
do with everybody trying to come back to
play in a pandemic is throw our hands up
over economics that I think is just kind
rule today at some point yeah and I
think that you know man oh man what I
just love to have a game every day I
mean it's just so wonderful you know you
know baseball just every day there's a
new story and god I miss it so much
in the meantime congrats on the success
of snowpiercer already picked up for a
second season it's good to see you back
on the screen too brother
in front of thank you man it's been
awesome and you know anytime anyone
offers you a part where you get to stand
next to Jennifer Connelly I think things
happen okay two things happen first
thing first thing if you're red blooded
American male which I am you say yes
I'll be there no see I wanted to be
standing there for 30 years and it's a
genocide that's the sad thing that's
what happens when you're there yes and
the actual the photos come back and the
footage comes back and you can't believe
how hideous you look nice it's like it's
like being Gollum in Lord of the Rings
okay there's like a promotional photo
next to her and I thought to myself you
know what I'm just like everyday you do
what you can we you work with what you
can rich I know you're looking at there
you say you know what I may not be the
most handsome creature but I'm looking
okay then you go to work and you wish
somebody had said to you you look
terrible you're terrible you ill you
just what is it you mean I understand
how you know people go get plastic
surgery because you're standing next to
Jennifer Kiley who's like a model I mean
she's stunning looking yes he's suddenly
nice person and she's massively talented
and I'm like Shrek next up we're looking
at you right now
daveed Diggs is also our handsome man
and supremely talented as well and but
you've got a nice suit on you've got a
nice suit your beard is trimmed Mike so
I'm gonna great I'm a great stage in my
five rips this is why okay there's so
many the the great villains now get to
be this great senators and congressmen
and people and and people that I can
play for the rest of my life that are
just you know a little bit overweight a
little bit uh I can't even say sin in
the hair I mean no hair it's just we we
get to be those people that had a
different aspect to other people's
attractiveness you stand next to me
you're stunningly attractive and that's
the that's what I bring to projects now
hey Mike let's just wrap it up with the
old Caddyshack line you're a tremendous
lunch don't worry
you're a tremendous sock well rich I
look forward to getting your kid at the
top of the lineup back in the not my if
the mighty mighty with Wilshire warriors
I was told this morning that I've taken
over a hosting job but you did about
eighteen years ago you hosted hot so
cool music for Peter Gammons back in
Boston a long time ago Peter Gammons can
shred by the way and he's a great guitar
is it a band I've seen I've what that's
when you were the Rick when I used to
they pass the baton to me because you're
you're smart and you're out here in Los
Angeles but we have we actually have an
event on in January 18th at him and Theo
Epstein for their foundation to me named
later they're gonna do a live event
online so we were talking about you this
morning fantastic I know compelling
radio it's a good brother you're you're
a blast to have around and again
congrats on snowpiercer again 9:00
Eastern on TNT on Sunday nights thanks
to the time you be right we'll be in
touch
right back at you that's Michael Mellon
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here